open up for new West world theories and
strangle a pedo with your bare hands
because we have some insane new theories
this week including clues that point to
who exactly is in Charlotte's body so
put on your favorite recording of you
are my sunshine because here we go
we start with a flashback of human
Charlotte Hale the night of the
west-world massacre she uses a host to
record a message a message that will
later find out is for her son Nathan
Nathan Hale also happens to be the name
of an American spy during the
Revolutionary War and his mother's name
was Elizabeth Hale which also happens to
be Charlotte's middle name Elizabeth
Hill Hale was hung for being a spy
perhaps foreshadowing what might become
of charlotte later on in the season the
title of this episode the absence of
field comes from a mark strand poem in
which the narrator feels uncomfortable
by his intrusion in the world constantly
moving so as to not disturb the world
around him in our case charlotte is this
intruder were treated to shots of
Charlotte's body being remade by Dolores
using the device found in Arnold's
abandoned home the question remains who
exactly is in her body I'll get to that
in a moment
Dolores needs host charlotte to keep up
the charade that she's still her human
self but they don't have much time as
we'll find out in a later scene an
inventory check of Westworld has found
that there are some acids that have yet
to be accounted for it's only a matter
of time before Delos realizes that some
of these hosts could have made it out of
the park
Dolores also shows charlotte four of the
five pearls smuggled out of West world
known as Bernards is the only one to
have a red hue to it red being the color
of the human host hybrids we saw in
season two hinting that Bernard is part
host part human we've seen Bernard turn
on and off these two sides it's likely
Dolores needs him because that human
part which is likely Arnold contains
some sort of data she needs last episode
i theorize these scans are Rehoboam
finding anomalies within the system and
here we have one showing elevated
scrutiny before zoning in on Charlotte
the anomaly it's picking up that
something just isn't right about her
Westworld taking a nod from michael bay
with this riot control transformer of
which 300 have been ordered these will
undoubtedly
used by Dolores in her upcoming
revolution Charlotte is informed that
someone has been buying vast amounts of
dello stock using a method called
creeping tender a business term for the
gradual accumulation of a target company
shares with the intent of controlling it
we're back with Caleb after the events
of episode 1 he's next to a wounded
Dolores and joins her in the ambulance
using his military skillset to give her
oxygen and prepare a stem pack after
their analysis the empties can't seem to
figure out what's wrong with her that's
because she's not human at all but
before Caleb can find out Dolores is
true nature they're pulled over by the
cops
but since caleb has his rico app he
knows these cops aren't really who they
say they are Dolores basically
terminators the [ __ ] out of them and
drives off telling Caleb II better get a
new name since he'll now be a wanted man
this is shown later on when he finds a
hit has been put on him and can we just
take a moment that the option not to
take the job is no I like being basic
Charlotte is front of dillos
headquarters which is actually the City
of Arts and Sciences Building in Spain
she's there literally clawing at her own
skin a metaphor for being trapped in
someone else's body and wanting to get
out she gets her first distorted message
here which she'll get several of over
the course of the episode when played in
order they create the melody for you are
my sunshine the song she promised to
sing to her son but never got to since
she died in Westworld
Charlotte is informed that the mystery
takeover is being done by Ciroc and that
his entire existence has been scrubbed
the only thing they know is that he's
worth a trillion dollars we haven't yet
seen human serac and I don't think we
can count his conversation with Maeve
since we aren't sure if that took place
in reality at all the other time we see
him he's a hologram leading me to
believe he might not be human at all
rather something created by Rehoboam as
a safety mechanism for its own
self-preservation it could even be the
real serac who was able to upload
himself into Robo mears ago being able
to live forever
Charlotte returns home to find her
ex-husband Jake pissed that she forgot
about picking up Nathan he seems to get
over that rather quickly
she also says goodnight to Nathan who
makes a remark about elephants elephants
are what Williams daughter Emily loved
while visiting Ross world they're also
what didn't arrive for Cersei and her
army and for those of you
who have seen Watchmen I'll just leave
this here notice also the arrows on
Nathan's pillows the same arrows found
in the opening credits and we can tell
that whoever's in this host is quite
empathetic to a child not having a
mother figure
hint hint back at Delos prompt and
informed Charlotte about the missing
control units and that there's a mole
high up in the company who is working
for their mystery buyer serac of course
we'll find out this mole was in fact
human Charlotte Charlotte meets Dolores
at an upscale bar wanting answers she's
been self harming because of the pain of
being in someone else's skin as well
later see she cuts herself in these
circular patterns which look a lot like
our Rehoboam circles Charlotte doesn't
get any answers from Dolores here and it
seems that Charlotte's identity is
ramping up to be the big reveal of the
season so who exactly is it the first
theory is that it's someone she loves
and trusts from Westworld most likely
Teddy or her father we get this shot of
Dolores cuddling Charlotte which is
similar to the one of her and Teddy and
we know that there is a loving history
between the two the problem with this
theory in any theory that it's someone
from West world is that it's just too
obvious and if this is gonna be the big
reveal there's really no gut punch
surprise in it how would you feel if it
was Teddy you'd probably be like oh okay
and then just move on it's not
surprising the second more interesting
theory is that Charlotte is a split
between Wyatt and Dolores remember that
Wyatt was the host created by Arnold
that he merged with Dolores to Massacre
all the hosts in season one if Dolores
found a way to separate the two she
could be controlled by Wyatt and give
Dolores to Charlotte hence why that
character is more sympathetic and caring
while Dolores is a killing machine even
in this shot you can see the duality of
the two characters like a yin and yang
with Dolores and black and Charlotte in
white the third and one I think is the
most batshit crazy theory is that
Charlotte is Caleb and it's so crazy it
just might be true it fills two
important criteria one it's surprising
and two it would make us rethink the
entire season and see it in a new light
just like the William is the man in
black reveal in season 1 of course in
order for this theory to be true it
would have to result in some serious
time [ __ ] which at this point is
almost impossible to plot out
however there is some other evidence
like how the episode focused heavily on
the relationship between mother and son
intertwined with the theme of
abandonment that point to Caleb as
Charlotte Nathan and Caleb both had
mothers who abandoned them which may be
why Caleb and Charlotte's body cries
when watching Charlotte's message to her
son it resonates with him he also wants
out of the body and cuts himself
something other hosts haven't really
done not to mention Charlotte is
overprotective of Nathan killing the
pedo with his bare hands whoever's in
control of Charlotte has an urge to
protect whereas I think other hosts
wouldn't be as inclined or maybe not go
to that extreme again this is still
super early but I want to hear what you
think in the comments below
dolorous basically tells charlotte that
they need to kill serac and fend off his
bid for del owes and in order to stop
that bid they need to provide a counter
offer in order to get that money she'll
need to visit quote an old friend now
the only person I know who has enough
money to possibly counter this is the
man in black who we know from the
trailers makes an appearance this season
Caleb goes to say goodbye to his mother
who suffers from schizophrenia she
doesn't know who he is whether that's a
result of the schizophrenia or something
else we aren't sure Caleb's on the run
since finding out that he's a wanted man
and is stopped by two men wanting to
know the whereabouts of Dolores he could
easily give her up but doesn't as will
later find out the reason behind this is
that she's quote the first real thing
that has happened to him in a long time
the irony being that she isn't real at
all Dolores asked Martin for info on
Caleb the man who saved her and
conveniently stumbles upon him being
picked up by these two men and Rehoboam
calculating that his life expectancy
will drop because of it Caleb saved her
now it's time for her to return the
favor at the construction site where
Caleb works he's interrogated using a
device called a drip which is found on
the roof of the mouth he's turned his
off and it needs to be short-circuited
in order for these men to control his
heartbeat
George Caleb's robotic co-workers senses
he's in danger and goes to help but his
push off the side Caleb then experiences
several flashbacks like the ocean where
apparently he will commit suicide the
spilled milkshake from what his mother
left him as a child and this cryptic
image of him and his military partner
Francis in the middle of some sort of
heist we can tell this is Caleb because
he's wearing
same jacket from his episode one
flashback I'm also getting the vibe and
maybe I'm just crazy you let me know in
the comments that Caleb and Francis may
have been romantically involved it would
give more weight in stakes to why he
misses him and if you believe the
Charlotte is Caleb theory it would
explain why she's so quick to jump him
Jake kind of looks like Francis Dolores
saves Caleb and breaks him free
symbolically signifying the start of him
breaking free of the system which has
kept him down they pass a building with
the word collaboration in the back which
I found pretty fun since the two will
collaborate together to bring down the
system in the diner where Caleb was
abandoned Dolores explains how she knows
all about him via Rehoboam a system
which has created a mirror of the real
world in order to predict the future and
plot out the pass of every human on
earth mirrors also happen to feature
prominently in this episode like the one
Charlotte holds up to her or even the
reflections of the thugs in the hospital
on the pier Dolores explains that
Rehoboam algorithm has predicted Caleb's
suicide 10 to 12 years in the future
in fact Rehoboam is so all-encompassing
in society that it is essentially
blocked him into being a construction
worker unfit for advancement or even
having children
this likely played a factor in why he
didn't get that job in episode 1 he has
merely been programmed to live this life
and can't do anything about it
just like how Dolores was programmed in
the way she lived her life in West world
as Dolores says they put you in a cage
and decided what your life would be she
confides in him telling him she's gonna
start a revolution and cut the cord of
this exploitive system what Caleb
doesn't know is that she wants to
destroy all of humanity Charlotte uses
the tones on her phone to call the
number to serac and arrange their
meeting the haunting violin piece that
plays here in the background is called
doomed by Moses some knee perhaps
another foreshadowing of what's to come
for her character Charlotte enters the
guarded home and is greeted by mantis
oops I mean Martel one of surak's
henchmen she puts on these special
glasses hinting that serac is indeed a
hologram we learned that human Charlotte
was working for serac and promised him
Delos is dirty little secret that Delos
was creating profiles of all the park
guests this data was uploaded at the end
of season 2 but the person who holds the
encryption key to it is Dolores hence
why serac wants
sir on its surface it seems like serac
is wanting to stop Dolores to save
humanity but I can't help but think
there is something else here something
more personal in the episode 4 preview
turn away for about 20 seconds if you
don't want to hear any of this we see a
young boy in a field overlooking what
appears to be a nuclear bomb destroying
a city in the west-world season
announcement trailer we see this
indicator of a thermonuclear incident in
Paris is the boy here serac or perhaps
his son I can't help but think there's
some connection here but it seems we'll
need to keep tuning in to get some
answers I hope you enjoyed this video
please make sure to LIKE and subscribe
and let me know your thoughts and
theories in the comments below you can
also follow me on Twitter at things
story whitey until next time remember
daddy loves you very much